Speaker 1: Republicans and right wingers are again
furious about Candy. Now, if this rings a bell,
it's because Tucker Carlson was furious
about Candy not that long ago. Check out
this clip from Oann where they are furious
that Eminem's have gone woke by introducing
a purple Eminem representing inclusiveness
and acceptance. Isn't that just terrible?
Speaker 3: Eminem's, you know, the candy we
all grew up eating. Well, they released their
brand new character in over a decade. And the
brand new character is Purple Eminem, which.
Speaker 4: Is supposed to represent.
Speaker 3: Inclusivity and acceptance.
I think it's a female character,
but I'm pretty sure they haven't
said maybe it's transgender. Joining me now.
Speaker 1: There you go for a very big explosive
reaction to the new Eminem's thing, they focus
on the dumbest things because they completely
lack an interest and ability to talk about actual
policy issues. There was recently a headline I'm
not covering. I don't know that it's a story in
and of itself, but I saw a headline this morning
about how in 2017, Barack Obama was telling
Democrats that there's really just no policy,
there's not even a semblance of policy from
Republicans, that the party is essentially a joke.
That's my word, not Barack Obama's. And this has
been increasingly the case for a while. And these
are when we say social issues, it's gone beyond
social issues. It's not even about like abortion
and gay marriage anymore. It's about Eminem's
and again, if it rings a bell. Tucker Carlson
also had a story back in January. It feels like
it's been years, but it was only about ten months
ago where Tucker was upset that the androgynous
design of Eminem's was no longer turning him on.
Quite frankly, remember this lunacy?
Speaker 3: Finally tonight, we don't
usually give story tips to NPR, but here's
a story they might want to cover pretty soon
and doubtless will. Eminem's The Candy
Company has just announced that it's
redesigning its cartoon. Characters to be
more gender inclusive. Bet you didn't think
Eminem's were pushing intolerance, but they
were. They've been changed. They're seeing
the changes right now on your screen. The green
Eminem, you will notice, is no longer wearing
sexy boots. She's wearing sensible sneakers. Why
the change? Well, according to Eminem's quote,
we all win when we see more women in leading roles
because leading women do not wear sexy boots.
Leading women wear frumpy shoes. The frumpy or the
better. That's the rule. The other big change is
that the Brown M&M has, quote, transitioned
from high stilettos to lower black heels,
also less sexy. That's progress. Eminem's will not
be satisfied until every last cartoon character is
deeply unappealing and totally androgynous until
the moment he would want to have a drink with
any one of them. That's the goal when you're
totally turned off. We've achieved equity.
Speaker 1: Chucker for a long time, was really
turned on by the design of Eminem's and all of a
sudden they are no longer turning him on, which is
a really sad thing. And Woke has one apparently.
Guys, they are focused on the dumbest things and
it is not. A glitch. It is a feature, not a bug.
They know there's no policy left. They know
they're losing on policy. You ask the American
people, hey, should the rich be taxed in order to
ensure that nobody falls below a certain level of
standard of living? Most people agree with that.
That's not good for policy when it comes to these
Republicans. So instead, they talk about I'm
no longer turned on by man am is because of
woke people. That that's that's where we
are. And it's not stopping any time soon